Bitte schön. Guten Tag. Schönen Tag.
Ich bin hier aus der Arsynthetik und möchte gerne das auf dem Gespräch führen.
Bevor Sie mir über Ihre Beschwerden erzählen, möchte ich einige persönliche Daten erfragen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Natürlich, sehr gerne.
Dann haben Sie bitte.
Mein Name ist Hund, Peter Hund.
Peter Hund.
Herr Hund, bitte schön, dass Sie mich über Ihren Namen langsamer werden.
H-U-M-D.
D, okay.
Und wieder Hund.
Ja. Herr Hund, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 41 Jahre alt.
41 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie geholfen?
Am 20. Januar 1982.
Wie groß und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin circa 80 Kilogramm und bin 1,65 m.
1,65 m?
Was führt Sie so, Herr Hund?
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich komme heute zu Ihnen, weil ich Schmerzen im Unterbrauch habe.
Schon seit 3 Tagen jetzt und die werden immer mehr.
Sind die Schmerzen plöselig oder langsam aufgetreten?
Also eher langsam aufgetreten, aber jetzt werden sie immer mehr.
Ja, ich verstehe.
3 Tage.
Wo ist die Schmerzen am Hersteller?
Wie bitte?
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen in der Körper?
Wo stark?
Wo stark sind die Schmerzen?
Im Unterbrauch.
Ganz unterbrauch oder rechts, links?
Also eher mittel und links.
Okay.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala?
Wobei von 0 bis 10.
Wobei 0 kann Schmerzen und 10 sehr stark Schmerzen.
6 bis 7.
Ja.
Können Sie genauer beschreiben, die Schmerzen?
Sind die Schmerzen eher dolfstähend brennend oder siehend?
Ja, eher so drückend und stächend, würde ich sagen.
Gebt es bestimmte Auslöder für die Schmerzen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Aber das ist auch, wenn ich zum Beispiel nach dem Stuhlgang,
das ist auch ein bisschen besser, oder wäre das Stuhlgang zu zaufe?
Ja.
Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hin aus?
Ein bisschen in die Leisten, aber nicht viel.
Sie haben gesagt, die Schmerzen sind immer da,
aber nun haben wir die Toilette ein bisschen besser.
Nee, eher auch schlimmer.
Schlimmer.
Ja, okay.
Und die sind auch abonnent, immer mehr und weniger.
Okay, wenn er formig ist, meine.
Ja, die kommen und gehen.
Auch nachts.
Wie ist die Schmerz?
Ich meine sie jetzt für die Schmerzen, weil ich Ibuprofen genommen habe.
Ich kann nicht verstehen.
Ich habe Ibuprofen genommen.
Ja, wie viel mal Niemunzi ein?
Ich glaube, das ist 3-4 Mal, habe ich eingenommen in den letzten 3 Tagen.
Total 3-4 Mal.
Ja, ich glaube schon.
Okay.
Also nicht täglich, sondern in den letzten 3 Tagen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie für ein Leben geschwärten?
Nein, das erste Mal.
Ich habe noch nie solche Schwere gehabt.
Waren Sie deswegen schon einmal in der Grenaz?
Ich habe Ihnen gesagt, ich habe diese Schmerzen noch nie gehabt.
Okay.
Deswegen war ich auch noch nie beim Arzt gewesen.
Haben Sie ungewöhnliches bemerkt über diese Schmerzen?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Zum Beispiel, nein, ich kann fragen.
Haben Sie viel bei Stärkulos oder nach Schweiß?
Also ich fühle mich krank, aber ich habe meine Fieber nicht gemessen.
Haben Sie karten Schweiß bemerkt?
Wie bitte?
Nein.
Haben Sie...
Ist Ihnen Schwindel hier oder Schweißbodenalgen?
Nein.
Haben Sie überkalt oder übergeben?
Ich habe mich tatsächlich vor 2 Tagen übergeben.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das damit in Verbindung steht.
Aber keine Erbüchern?
Ich habe mich übergeben, doch.
Okay.
Übergeben?
Ich habe mich einmal übergeben.
Einmal.
Wie sieht die Erbrochen aus?
Das war so geldlich.
Leiden Sie unter Appetitlösigkeit?
Nein.
Eigentlich nicht.
Im letzten Zeit haben Sie verlohen.
Was habe ich verloren? Ich verstehe Sie sehr schlecht.
Ja, ich weiß.
Im letzten Zeit haben Sie Apotheos übergeben.
Nein, eigentlich gleich geblieben.
Haben Sie Schlafstörungen?
Nein, aber in den letzten 3 Tagen, weil ich Schmerzen habe,
kann ich nicht durchschlafen.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang?
Sie haben gesagt 2-mal.
Aber ja, bitteschön.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang?
Ich habe keine Probleme,
aber ich habe in den letzten 3 Tagen so wechselnden Stuhlgang.
Mal weich, mal etwas härter.
Ich kann nicht verstanden.
Ich habe eher so wechselnden Stuhlgang.
Mal ist es sehr weich, mal ist es etwas härter.
Okay, okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasalas?
Nein.
Haben Sie Bemerkte im Stuhl?
Haben Sie im Stuhlbolut Bemerkte?
Nein.
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzklopfen oder Atemnot?
Gebt es in irakrankingesichte?
Ich habe wieder Zuckerkrankungen,
noch habe ich keine Zuckerkrankungen.
Ich habe keine Zuckerkrankungen,
Ich habe wieder Zuckerkrankungen,
noch habe ich einen Lutotruck.
Nein.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay, würden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ich wurde schon mal operiert, ja.
Was operiert wurden Sie?
In der Kindheit wurden meine Mande entfernt.
Wie war die Art, die Sie?
Wie alt ich war?
Ja.
10 Jahre war ich.
Gab es Konflikationen während der OP?
Nein, nicht als Wüste.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder delegativ Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich nehme Schilddusen Medikamente ein.
Wie heißt die Medikamente?
Das Medikament heißt L-Tyroxin.
Wie viele Dosierungen nehmen Sie ein?
Ich glaube, das sind 25 Mikrogramm.
Täglich?
Jeden Morgen, ja.
Jeden Morgen?
Haben Sie weitere Medikamente?
Das war es?
Ich täglich mich manchmal, ich nehme Koffein ein,
wenn ich Schmerzen habe.
Haben Sie gegeneffacht aller Genöden oder Unverzwecklichkeit?
Nein.
Nicht als Wüste.
Ist Ihnen alle Infugren bekommen?
Was?
Die meint ihr?
Ja.
Die alle geübt.
Was heißt denn alles?
Kinderinfugren oder Corona.
Corona bin ich dreimal geimpft.
Ich glaube, ich bin auch gegen meine Kindheitserkrankungen geimpft.
Das weiß ich aber nicht.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche.
Ich finde, ich finde, ich rauche Sie täglich.
10 Stück am Tag ungefähr.
10 Stück?
Seit wann rauchen Sie?
Schon lange seit, bestimmt.
25 Jahre, bestimmt.
Alles ist nicht ganz genau.
Ja.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Manchmal, wenn wir auf dem Geburtstag oder wenn wir
eine ganze Zeit da sind.
Ich habe auch noch eine Frage,
die Sie sagen.
Ich habe lange nicht gehört.
Ja?
Nein.
Ich will also fragen.
Ich habe keine keine Kindergänger in der Familie.
Ich meine oder ich meine Kinder in der Brille.
Was heißt denn wichtig? Was meinen Sie mit wichtig?
Zum Beispiel Suka kranker, Herz krank oder Bluthochdruck.
Und so mein Vater hat eine Krebserkrankung, wenn das wichtig ist?
Ja natürlich.
Eine Krebserkrankung, genau. Und meine Mutter hat Rhythmusstörungen am Herzen.
Ja ich muss fragen, ihr Vater lebt ihr Vater im Moment?
Er ist verstorben.
Wie war er?
65.
Welche Krebs wissen Sie?
Der hatte Darmkrebs.
Darmkrebs, tut mir leid.
Und ihr Mutter lebt auch?
Sie lebt noch, sie hat Medikamente ein.
Wie alt ist sie?
Sie ist jetzt auch 65 Jahre alt.
Haben Sie eine Schwester?
Ich habe eine Schwester.
Sind Sie gesurt?
Ich oder meine Schwester?
Ihre Schwester.
Ich bin Informatiker.
Das sind zwei Schwester.
Ich habe eine Schwester, die ich gestorben habe.
Ich habe eine Familie.
Ich bin ein Schwester.
Ich habe eine Schwester.
Ich bin eine Schwester.
Und ich bin ein Schwester.
Sie lebt auch?
Ich denke, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestartet.
Und ich bin sehr gespannt.
Was haben Sie denn? Ich bin auch schon sehr gespannt.
Was haben Sie denn?
Ich werde für die Verstärkungen von den Verstärkungen
dann für die Verstärkungen von den Verstärkungen von den Verstärkungen
Wir müssen einfach unter uns durchführen.
Was machen Sie denn bitte?
Ja, Abdomenzone.
Was ist das?
Nein, Ultraschall.
Balutraschall.
Okay.
Ist das Operation oder was das?
Ja, es ist so für etwas zu sagen.
Nein, nein, keine Operation.
Es ist eine Schmerzlos- und strahlendurchunterzuckung-Methode.
Ja, mit Schallemwellen wird Unterzuckung ja auch organisch.
Das ist wie eine Röntgen oder wie das?
Nein, nein, nur Ultraschall-Wellen.
Es ist nicht Röntgen.
Also keine Tomografie?
Nein, nein.
Ist es eine Röhre oder so was?
Nur ein Probe benutzen wir.
Und ein Probe, ja.
Nur Probe oder?
Wie bitte?
Eine Stuhlprobe?
Nein, ein wie ein Geräte,
Was kann ich erklären?
Das kann ich erklären.
Leider.
Okay.
Geben Sie mir auch Schmerzmedikamente?
Ja, ich kann geben.
Aber ich rate Ihnen ein bisschen aushalten.
Können Sie das machen?
Warum?
Weil wenn Sie ein Medikament eingenommen haben,
manchmal Ihre Beschwerden verwechseln
und dann unsere Diagnose verwechseln können.
Und wann kriege ich Schmerzmedikamente?
Weil ich habe jetzt wieder sehr stark Schmerzen.
Oh, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Okay, wissen Sie nicht.
Okay.
Dann warte ich noch ein bisschen.
Ich habe gesagt, ich bin sehr aufgeregt.
Dann warte ich noch ein bisschen, bis die Blutuntersuchungen da sind.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen andere noch Fragen?
Ja.
Ein Moment.
Ja, ja.
Entschuldigung,
meine Kollegen haben viele Fragen gefragt.
Aber ich möchte ein paar Fragen über Schmerzen fragen.
Bitte schön, fragen Sie mich.
Ja, wo genau diese Schmerzen,
die könzige Bitte diese Schmerzen,
genau lokalisieren?
Diese Fragen hat schon gestellt, Issa.
Noch andere Fragen.
Aber ich kann...
Unterbau mehr?
Linke Zeit.
Link und Mitte.
Ja, hat gesagt.
Könnten wir Arsatzgebirge anfangen, Murat Özem?
Aber keine Ahnung, in diesem Fall, über in diesem...
Ja, über über über.
Unsere Kollegen hat heute...
Oberarzt, unsere Kollegen hat heute...
Ich bin da im Krankenhaus gegangen und deswegen
viele
falsche
falsche stellte Fragen oder?
Ja, falsche stellte Fragen,
sondern auch...
Alles.
Ja, sie war ein bisschen aufgeregt.
Ja.
Aber das ist, glaube ich, nochmal.
Dann machen wir das zusammen mit dem Oberarzt, ja?
Okay, bitte schön.
Vielleicht kann der Oberarzt etwas helfen.
Rene, ja.
Guten Tag.
Hallo.
Mein Name ist Rene Burak.
Heute habe ich bei Peter Hund
eine Annäßige Gespräche durchgeführt.
Herr Hund ist ein und 40 Jahre alt,
80 Kilogramm schwer und 1,75 Meter...
Aus?
Ja.
Er kam zu uns wegen
seit 3 Tagen, bis zu Ende,
langsam aufgetretener
Unterbauchschmerzen.
Oder?
Ja, unterbauchschmerzen.
Ja, die Schmerzen
stark sind im Link- und Mittellunterbauch.
Schmerzintensität liegt bei 6 bis 7 von 10.
Und Schmerzen sind aus Drücken und aus...
Ja, und nicht der.
Keine bestimmte Auslöser für die Schmerzen.
Und der Patient beschrieb,
der Patient berichtet das Schmerz
schlechter nach dem Toilette gehen.
Und...
Und ja, er nimmt
in den letzten 3 Tagen
3-4 Mal über einen Genomen
hat und sie haben...
Sie hat keine Frühe erleblich werden.
Und sie fühlt sich
fühlt sich
fieberabakain gemessen hat.
Und er
er legt an Übelkeit seit 2 Tagen.
Und einmal
Erbrechen hat.
Ja, die Erbrochene ist gelblich.
Und er hat keine Appetitlösigkeit.
Er hat in so einem Nie
seit 3 Tagen in so einem Nie wegen Schmerzen.
Hat er in so einem Nie oder Schlafsturm?
Schlafsturm. In so einem Nie, oder?
In so einem Nie ist er so, wenn man gar nicht schlafen kann.
Okay.
Schlafsturm.
Schlafstürungen, weil er die Schmerzen nicht hat.
Okay. Er hat auch seit 3 Tagen
Stuhlwechsel.
Okay. Ja.
Er hat und
anderer Begleit
Symptom ist unauffällig.
Symptom. Ja.
Hat er Blut im Stuhl? Hat er Blut im Stuhl?
Ich kann nicht ganz verstehen, aber
er hat gesagt, Stuhlwechsel.
Manchmal, der Verstopfung, ich kann nicht ganz verstehen.
Also manchmal flüssig, manchmal fest im Stuhlgang.
Meint er wahrscheinlich.
Also manchmal Durchfall, manchmal Verstopfen.
Ja. Ja.
Manchmal Diarrhe, manchmal Obsipation.
Ja, ich verstehe das, aber ich kann nicht erklären.
Okay. Hat er Blut im Stuhl gehabt?
Nein, nein.
Er hat kein Blut bemerkt im Stuhl.
Okay.
Und ja, das war es.
Aber hat keine Ahnung fertig aus.
Okay. Hat er irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen?
Ja.
Es gibt keine Vorerkrankungen.
Nein.
In Operationen.
Hat er irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen?
Nehmt der Medikamente ein.
Regelmäßig.
Ah, ja, aber er hat gesagt, keine Vorerkrankungen.
Ja, richtig.
Ich hab nicht bemerkt.
Natürlich.
Ja, er hat gesagt, keine Vorerkrankungen hat.
Aber er nimmt regelmäßig als Roxyin 40 mg täglich.
Deswegen hat er Schulte-Große.
25 mg.
25?
Ja, aber 50.
25.
Was hat er dann für eine Vorerkrankung, wenn er Eltyroxyin handelt?
Hypothiose.
Haben Sie das gefragt? Hat er das?
Wenn jemand regelmäßig Medikamente nimmt,
müssen Sie fragen, warum er diese nimmt?
Ja, natürlich.
Hat er vielleicht eine Hashimoto?
Hat er etwas anderes? Hat er eine einfache Schilddrüse unter Funktionen?
Hat er Schilddrüsenknoten?
Hat er noch die Schilddrüse? Hat er Operationen gehabt?
Okay.
Ja.
Hat er Pro-Operationen gehabt?
In Operationen ist eine Tonzillektomie mit 10 Telefon-Siehren bekannt.
Keine Komplikation.
Und er nimmt auf bei Bedarf über den Gruffen,
die Gengang Schimertsen.
Hat er in der letzten Zeit ein Unfall von Schilddrüsenknoten
gehabt?
Ja, natürlich.
Sie haben nicht gefragt.
Haben Sie nicht gefragt?
Okay.
Leider.
Aber kann ich während pro-Operationen Untersuchung fragen?
Okay.
Der Patient beschreibt jetzt Unterbauchschmerzen.
Er links zeigt dich.
Richtig.
Und Sie wissen noch nicht genau, was Sie haben.
Sie wissen noch nicht genau,
was Sie haben.
Richtig.
Und Sie wissen noch nicht genau, was Sie haben könnten.
Okay.
Was machen wir denn für Diagnostik mit den Patienten jetzt?
Was würden Sie machen mit den Patienten?
Ja, so erst ich werde körperlich untersuchen,
besonders abkasten und abhören.
Wie ist der Darngeräusch?
Ich werde abtesten,
ob ich auf der Türkei oder auf der Lostaschmerz
unterlaufen.
Und dann würde ich gerne Labor untersuchen.
Was ist das für ein Labor?
Welche Parameter?
Bitte machen Sie den Arpies.
Welche Parameter haben Sie?
Der Arpies.
Was ist das für ein Labor?
Welche Parameters?
Ja.
Und?
Was hat sonst in welchem Blutpferde noch?
Leberwerte, Galdenwerte, Schollostase?
Ja, Galdenwerte, Milamertia natürlich.
Sie haben gesagt, er nimmt schilddrüsen Medikamente ein.
Ich würde auch schilddrüsen Medikamente ein.
Ja, natürlich.
3, T4 und TCH.
Ja, genau.
TCH reicht erst mal aus.
FC4, FC3 können Sie nachmelden, wenn TSA auffällig sein soll.
Aha.
Müssen Sie nicht sofort mit abnehmen.
Wann war er denn zuletzt beim Hausarzt gewesen?
Haben Sie ihn gefragt?
Nicht gefragt.
Ja, nicht gefragt.
Wann waren in die letzte Hausarzt?
Besuch, genau.
Ja.
Okay, Sie haben jetzt den Blut ab.
Sie haben ihn untersucht, ne?
Körperlich untersucht.
Sie nehmen Blut ab.
Was machen Sie noch?
Wir vom Eschmacher, die Plastik ist ab.
Ich z Ah, das ist eine Tch.
Ich muss die Plastik hervornehmen.
Sie können noch etwas am Labor messen.
Stuhldiagnostik.
Stuhldiagnostik dauert lange, dauert 3 Tage.
Das hilft uns jetzt hier nicht.
Ja, wenn mich Stuhl dieagnosik macht, aber wir können noch etwas kontrollieren.
Den Urin.
Urin müssen wir kontrollieren.
Er hat Unterbauchschmerzen.
Er könnte auch Haumblasenschmerzen haben.
Er könnte Blut, Mikrohematurie haben.
Das wissen wir nicht.
Ja, aber er hat gesagt, wir können Schwer-Kalk-Auto-Probleme bei Mvasalasen oder...
Aber vielleicht sieht er das nicht.
Mikrohematurie können Sie nicht sehen.
Ah, asymptomatische.
Mikrohematurie, ne?
Das gehört zu einer normalen Diagnostik mit dazu.
Bei Unterbauchschmerzen immer auch Urin kontrollieren.
Egal, egal, was er hat.
Die Digital-Untersuchung, oder?
Digital, richtig, ganz genau.
Digital-Rectal-Untersuchung, auf jeden Fall.
Aber ich dachte, das wäre vielleicht mit der körperlichen Untersuchung mit dabei gewesen.
Und Sie haben jetzt...
Sie machen auch einen Ultraschall, okay.
Was kann dieser Patient denn an Differenzialdiagnosen haben?
Was kommt Ihnen in den Sinn?
Er hat auch Schmerzen, Mitte und Linkszeichen.
Was könnte es sein?
Also, wie viele Diagnose?
Differenzialdiagnose, Dar-Probleme, welche?
Das Renteritis zum Beispiel.
Das Renteritis kann sein, richtig, weiter.
Weil er hat Diagnose manchmal.
Was noch, was noch, was kann es noch sein?
Die neuen Arbeitsdiagnosen.
Kann er einen Amtix-Infekt haben?
Rolitis?
Rolitis.
Wie viele Diagnose haben wir hier?
Er kann ein Legas-Tryptis haben.
Er kann ein Handwechsinfekt haben.
Er kann einen Nierenkolik haben.
Das passt aber nicht mit dem Stuhlgang zusammen.
Was kann er noch haben?
Was fällt Ihnen ein?
Sie müssen ein bisschen überlegen.
Können Sie mich hören?
Diagnose.
Er kann eine Vettikulitis haben, richtig.
Was noch?
Kolonkarcinum.
Kolonkarcinum kann er haben.
Sehr gut.
Ist die Kollegin noch da?
Frau Wurom, oder ist sie weg?
Ich bin da.
Ach so, ich höre Sie nicht.
Ja, ja, ich bin da.
Kolitis ulcerosa?
Ja, könnte er haben.
Wäre meistens mit Blut und Schleinig im Stuhl.
Nicht mit Verstopfung.
Sie müssen ja, wenn Sie einen Patienten haben,
in der Notaufnahme,
müssen Sie eine Arbeitsdiagnose haben.
Verdachtdiagnosen haben.
Ja, so jetzt kommt der Patient
und er hat erhöhte Entzündungswerte.
Kolitis ulcerosa?
Neukutzuttenes und hoch.
Ja, was könnte er haben?
Urin ist unaufwällig.
Kolitis ulcerosa, akut form.
Ja, könnte sein.
Könnte sein, richtig.
Reizdam-Syndrom könnte auch sein.
Ja, könnte sein.
Wer bei der Ausschlussdiagnose,
Reizdam-Syndrom können Sie nur die Diagnose stellen,
wenn Sie alles andere ausgeschlossen haben.
Sie können dem Patienten, den Sie zum ersten Mal sehen,
nicht sagen,
Sie haben eine Reizdam-Syndrom, das geht nicht.
Sie müssten vorher Untersuchungen machen,
damit Sie diese Diagnose stellen können.
Es ist eine Ausschlussdiagnose.
Wenn der Patient jetzt ein,
er hat erhöhte Entzündungszeichen.
Und er hat auch Leukozytten, die erhöht sind.
Und er hat Schmerzen.
Was könnte er haben?
Der Urin ist unaufwällig.
Frau Wurram.
Ein Mesenta-Problem, aber.
Also hier muss man überlegen, ich helfe Ihnen mal.
Ich würde arbeiten mit der Diagnose,
die Vertikulitis vielleicht.
Linksseitige Unterbauchschmerzen nach Mitte,
ausstrahlend oder mittig.
Aber er hat ja in der Vorgeschichte auch den Vater,
der einen Kolonkarzin umracht.
Richtig?
Deswegen muss man immer hellhörig sein hier.
Was machen wir mit dem Patienten,
wenn wir die Arbeitsdiagnose, die Vertikulitis haben?
Aber ich war im Vertikulitis,
die Vertikulitis hat nicht immer Blut im Stuhl.
Es gibt verschiedene Stadien von die Vertikulitis.
Jetzt muss man nochmal durchlesen einmal.
Okay.
Es gibt die unkomplizierte,
komplizierte Fleckmüllöse.
Und die Vertikulitis, die Vertikulitis,
die Vertikulitis, die Vertikulitis,
die Vertikulitis, die Vertikulitis,itions yesterday.
Aber pünkt wahre große Fleckmüllöse,
ruptuierte.
Das Thema und die Vertikulitis,
Kennen Sie die Therapie?
Wirken Sie die Vertikulitis Dietz?
Ricianuno so wunderbar verwickelt.
aufnehmen? Ja, natürlich. Die Patientin soll aufnehmen, stationieren behandelt.
Ja, stationieren angenommen. Kann man stationieren aufnehmen, um zu gucken, ob
alles okay ist, auch mit der Vorgeschichte. Man muss diesen Patienten aber, wenn er
nicht zu hohe Entzündungswert hat, kann man ihn auch nach Hause entlassen.
Ja, und im Ultraschall, wenn nichts auffälliges ist, kann man ihn auch nach Hause
entlassen mit Antibiotische Therapie. Okay. Und dann muss man ihm empfehlen, dass man
im Verlauf in den nächsten Monaten oder Wochen lieber eine Darmspilung machen
lässt. Okay. Eine Kolonoskopie. Aber als Luftparameter, wenn er
als Luftparameter erhöht, müssen wir abwarten. Okay. Dann darf man keine Kolonoskopie machen.
Ich meine, wenn die Ersidukparameter erhöht, müssen wir die Patientin stationieren aufnehmen.
Ja, es kommt auch, wenn die Ersidukparameter erhöht sind, nicht unbedingt, aber wenn
sie sehr stark erhöht sind, ja. Okay. Und dann weitere Therapie. Am besten ist, den Patienten aufzunehmen.
Dann kann man intravenöse Antibiotika machen, zum Beispiel. Man kann ihn vielleicht nach
zwei, drei Tagen wieder entlassen. Man muss aber nicht. Man kann, man muss nicht. Man kann
ihn auch mit Antibiotikum am Land behandeln. Es kommt immer auf die Situation an.
Ja. Es gibt auch die Vertikulitis-Patienten, denen muss man gar keine Antibiotikum geben.
Man muss nur abwarten. Ja. Das gibt es auch. Manchmal haltet das auch von alleine.
Ja, gibt es sonst irgendwie Fragen noch, irgendwelche Unklarheiten? Okay.